I've heard that you occasionally like  all of us you get frustrated you get  angry about something that's happened to  you either at work or in your private  life and you like to vent it through  songwriting is that right with all this  stuff that's been going on with Batman  the the paparazzi attentions been a  little intense so I actually wrote a rap  song about it it's in the style of Lil  Wayne okay yo I'm a paparazzi I don't  play no Yahtzee I go pop pop pop pop pop  pop my camera's up your crotch see I  tell the truth from what I see and sail  it to Perez Hilton don't call me scuzzy  making money that's my job celeb  photography what hell no I'm not needy  I'm legit now sucker Roxie  don't act so hotsy-totsy [ __ ] I know  that you from Jersey scream all you want  won't make me stop pop pop pop pop pop I  know you love to feel my power  [Applause]